here with reaction the man himself vice
president of the united states
uh mike pence mr vice president thank
you for being with us
good to be with you sean okay well you
i can imagine that you got a little bit
different treatment
than kamala harris but
let's stick to substance and the issues
here i think that's important
i argue this will be the biggest choice
election
tipping point election even in history
your initial reaction well the stakes in
this
election have never been higher but
following joe biden's decision
to name a california liberal like kamala
harris to the ticket
the choice has never been clearer look
four years ago when president
trump called and asked me to join this
ticket i said yes
in a heartbeat because i believed in his
vision
to rebuild our military to revive our
economy by cutting taxes rolling back
regulation fighting for free fair trade
unleashing american energy standing up
for life and liberty and appointing
conservatives to our courts
and standing with law enforcement at
every level and
and joe biden's decision to add kamala
harris to the ticket confirms
everything president trump and i have
been saying and that is that
joe biden and the democratic party have
been overtaken
by the radical left kamala harris
like joe biden supports higher taxes
socialized medicine open borders
abortion on demand
and where joe biden said he'd be willing
to cut funding to police she said
recently that
that she thought that we should
reimagine the police in this country
and i i just have to tell you i you know
i i like the match-up
it you know it's on sean i can't wait to
get back out there i'll be in
iowa tomorrow telling the story of what
this president has done
how we made this country stronger more
prosperous in our first three years how
president trump has seen us
through the worst pandemic in a hundred
years
and how we've already created more jobs
in the last three months than joe biden
and barack obama
created in their eight years in office
i'm excited to tell the story
i think kamala harris being added to the
ticket just confirms
what president trump and i have been
saying all along you know
mr vice president four years ago i
look i'm now 33 years in radio if you
can believe it i know i look so much
younger my 25th year at fox
and you know i said to this audience and
i have to always be honest i said donald
trump i've known him for
about 25 years now i said he will govern
as a conservative
every issue you just mentioned is
it is transformational and as much as he
kept every promise
every single one of them there's not one
thing he said that he wanted to get done
that really has not gotten done
right and i and i look at it and i look
at the results
and results matter to me i can't think
of a single accomplishment of joe biden
in 50 years of the swamp that helped
benefit the american people can you
and i know kamala harris is going to be
out there attacking the president daily
if i was him i would ignore every word
she says and focus on what he's done and
what he plans to do
well i think it's a reason why you see
the support all across the country
that you see for this president and for
our administration
and that's that president trump has done
exactly what he told the american people
he would do we rebuilt our military
restored the arsenal
of democracy uh and and now america's
military is stronger than ever before
but this president by by cutting taxes
by rolling back more regulations than
any president in american history
by fighting for the kind of free and
fair trade like the usmca that was a win
for american manufacturing a win for
american farmers
a trade deal that kamala harris was one
of only 10 members of the senate
to vote against and you see his
commitment to to follow through on
appointing conservatives to our courts
at every level
contrast that with now joe biden and
kamala harris
they actually want to raise taxes by
four trillion dollars
they want to do their own version of the
green new deal
of a two trillion dollar massive
environmental agenda
they're going to appoint activists to
our court they're going to support
taxpayer funding of abortion uh they
support
uh open borders and and the the truth of
the matter is beyond all of that with
everything that's happening
in chicago and new york and portland
and seattle you have in president trump
a leader who is standing without apology
with the men
and women of law enforcement and in joe
biden and kamala harris and the
democratic party and the radical left
you have people talking about cutting
funding to law enforcement
a party that is advocating defunding law
enforcement
the choice could not be clear and
as i said i can't wait to get out there
and get out there and tell that story
and i think
the american people are going to vote
for four more years of president donald
trump
in the white house mr vice president i i
think i'm a pretty good political
observer
and if you notice the the debate when
kamala harris
went after joe biden on his racial
positions which are
you know imagine if donald trump
supported the guy that filibustered the
civil rights act and
talked about not wanting his kids to be
involved in integration or
quote a racial jungle i could imagine
the media would have very different
reaction to joe biden
and as i look at the scene it's actually
on the screen right now
she to me and you will be debating her
it looked to me that that line was
prepared that line was memorized and
that my
line was delivered somewhat perfectly
pretty devastating to joe biden
although she feels very differently now
apparently
did you get the same feeling i did it
that was all prepared ahead of time
well look i i i think uh you know i
think she is a skilled debater
uh but i can't wait to get to salt lake
city and be on the stage with her to
compare
joe biden's nearly 50 years in public
life the agenda of the radical left
the agenda that she's embraced
throughout her political career
with the results of this president and
this administration
i mean joe biden and kamala harris come
from a party that's been talking about
helping african americans for decades
this is a president who because of the
policies we advanced
we actually saw the lowest unemployment
ever recorded for african americans
we saw the creation of thousands of
opportunity zones
in creating billions of dollars of
investment in our inner cities
this is a president who doubled the
school choice program
here in our nation's capital has been
fighting for educational opportunities
for every american especially our
our minority communities and that's a
record that i
i'm excited to talk about this is a
president who's been out there
fighting for the american dream for
every american regardless of race or
creed
or color while the other side does the
talk and we're going to talk about what
we've done for the american people
and what we're going to do with four
more years of president donald trump in
the white house
i would like to you know i would like to
not have one vote cast
until at least one debate between the
president and joe biden joe biden says
he can't wait
says he wants to do it the president has
offered to have one
16 states will be voting before early
voting before the first debate
i think that has to change do you agree
there's no question and i know uh the
campaign is reaching out
look particularly in the times in which
we live as as we continue every day to
work
to put the coronavirus in the past we're
seeing positive trends across the sun
belt
we're seeing leveling trends uh in other
states around the country where every
day
one day closer to having more medicines
and more vaccines
to your point sean uh we're going to be
we're going to be seeing states around
the country
start early voting in a in a matter of a
month or so and i think the american
people ought to hear
uh from this president and hear from joe
biden on the stage
to talk about their competing visions
for this country
because they could not be more different
i mean i truly do believe that president
trump's
vision in our first three years was
proven out
i mean we made america more prosperous
than ever before this president
and his policies with our allies in
congress
created the conditions the most the most
prosperous
economy in the history of the world and
when the coronavirus pandemic struck
it's that solid foundation that
president trump poured
that's allowed us to add nine million
jobs back
as we open up this economy just in the
last three months alone
and again joe biden i mean when people
go into the voting booth
on november 3rd or when they when they
participate in early voting before then
they deserve to know that that here as
we as our
country is coming back from this uh this
this uh massive pandemic that at its
height costs
22 million american jobs joe biden and
kamala harris
their prescription is to raise taxes by
four trillion dollars
and impose an avalanche of regulations
like the green new deal on the american
economy
and uh and you know it's no real
surprise
it's what it's what joe biden and barack
obama did in their
eight years they tried to tax and spend
and regulate us into prosperity and they
oversaw the slowest
economic recovery since the great
depression i want to say it again sean
it's remarkable that because of the
foundation president trump poured
we've actually seen this economy create
more jobs in the last three months
than joe biden and the last
administration created in their entire
eight years the american people deserve
to understand those two competing
visions and when they do
i believe they're going to vote to
re-elect president donald trump
mr vice president we always thank you
for your time thank you for being with
us